what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and marvel studios has
revealed all of phase five and some of
phase six or
have they yesterday i did a video
talking about what the other unannounced
phase six projects could be from x-men
to nova to armor wars but today i
actually want to go back to phase 5
because i believe that phase 5 has not
been totally revealed yet and i think
that there might be some secret projects
to phase 5 as well that marvel is
waiting to reveal at d23 in a couple of
months and they're just trying to
surprise us so phase 5 might have even
more projects coming which sounds like a
lot because it actually is but if you
consider all of the properties that
marvel studios has now they have a lot
that they can work with between old
characters and new characters but let's
dive into why i think there still could
be some unannounced projects for phase 5
and it actually starts with deadpool 3.
before marvel studios released phase 5
and some of phase 6 at san diego
comic-con they had actually given us
release dates for untitled movies to hit
theaters coming on november 3rd 2023
february 16th may 3rd july 26th and
november 8th of 2024 now all but one of
these slots were filled with blade
captain america new world order the
thunderbolts and the fantastic four but
the february 16th of 2024 slot was left
empty we don't have a movie and it is
for a movie in this official release
date slot yet and that's for one of two
reasons one is that marvel has simply
moved this date however since they
didn't move any of the other dates that
they had already marked down it seems
more likely that they are simply saving
this reveal for d23 in a couple of
months for those who are not aware
disney's d23 day is a big day for marvel
studios they have a really big panel and
we know that marvel studios had to save
some announcements for d23 they couldn't
release everything at sdcc which is why
we only got part of phase six but it
looks like we only got part of phase
five as well granted most of it is full
but there could be a few projects that
are going to be announced pretty soon
and many believe that this slot that has
been left open is actually for deadpool
3. and the reason for that is that all
of the upcoming movies that don't have a
slot yet they don't have a crew and they
haven't started production whereas
deadpool 3 has a crew and is in the
beginning stages of film prep now two of
the biggest announcements that people
were anticipating of course were for
mutants
x-men and deadpool and some fans were
pretty bummed that we didn't get an
announcement for either however again
marvel had to save some big
announcements after all they did
announce two avengers films which is
pretty huge so we know a deadpool
announcement is coming we also know an
x-men announcement is coming but
deadpool might actually go in phase 5.
now if it's not deadpool then there are
actually quite a few other options it
has been reported that a world war hulk
movie is being developed at marvel
studios right now and it seems pretty
clear that mark ruffalo is not done with
marvel studios in fact we have seen him
twice now after avengers end game one is
in the post-credits scene for shanghai
and the legend of the tin rings and the
second time we've seen him is of course
in shihok but here's the kind of weird
catch in shihok he is still very much
professor hulk but in the post credit
for chang chi he is back to human form
and it looks like his arm is still hurt
so it seems like there's still a lot of
story to be told about bruce banner and
the hulk and since there have already
been a few reports about world war hulk
that could mean that it is secretly in
development and could take this slot now
i also want to mention that another
project could be coming that is not
actually for this slot but could
actually get his own new slot because he
typically doesn't ever have a place on
any of these phase announcements and
that is spider-man due to the
relationship between sony and marvel
sony owning the rights to spider-man but
marvel working out a deal with sony to
where spider-man could be in the mcu
spider-man doesn't ever actually get a
slot on the phase lineups if you take a
look back at the official phase reveals
you won't find the spider-man movies on
there and here's the deal kevin feige
has already confirmed with executive
producer over at sony amy pascal that
they are already working on a fourth
spider-man film with tom holland so if
they are already working on it it could
take a slot in phase 5. they wouldn't
announce this at san diego comic-con and
they might not even announce this at d23
because they typically don't it's
typically a sony announcement but here's
the other thing they have also announced
secret wars where universes collide and
incursions happen which was mentioned in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness where we are going to see a
whole bunch of different variants from
different universes all actually be
together now this has already happened
with spider-man no way home so it would
make sense that the next one would kind
of be a little bit about it as well
especially if mj and ned are actually
going to be filled back in on what
actually happened and kind of given
their memories back they'll have to dive
in at least a little bit to what
happened with andrew garfield and toby
maguire spider-man so spider-man might
not even have a slot in phase 5 but
could still be in phase 5. now keep in
mind there are some specials coming out
as well like the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special werewolf by night and
the i am groot special none of these are
listed for phase four even when kevin
feige recently showed the ending of
phase four these projects were not on
there spiderman no way home was on there
but this is after the fact remember sony
always wants to do the reveal themselves
so there are probably other projects
like that that are going to be in phase
5 that aren't put on this phase list now
another movie that is reportedly being
worked on right now is a solo scarlet
witch film this could still very much be
in phase 5 as well especially if there
are still going to be multiverse
connections to the scarlet witch there
might even be a dr doom connection here
because if doctor doom is going to be
one of the main villains of phase 5 and
6 along with king the conqueror of
course it would make sense for him to
come in sooner rather than later and he
is one of the greatest sorcerers alive
so it would make sense that the scarlet
witch might actually catch his attention
this could take up that phase 5 slot but
it also could be going into phase six as
well now if we're going into secret wars
it would make sense that they would
actually introduce the character captain
britain and there have actually been
reports that marvel is planning on
introducing captain britain to the mcu
now if you don't know who captain
britain is he is supposed to be the
protector of earth 616 and is actually a
part of the multiversal team the captain
britain corps they are each responsible
for protecting their own universe in the
multiverse so you can obviously see how
this character would fit very very well
leading up to avengers secret wars where
eventually the multiverse will kind of
shatter now the last one that i think
could be in phase five is actually ghost
writer and coincidentally enough kevin
feige was actually talking about ghost
rider in an interview with mtv
immediately after san diego comic con
and as you start to see you talk about
ghost rider we've got blade we've got dr
stranger at the supernatural right
angles we've got the street level with
our announcement of daredevil and of
course spidey going into the street
level uh heroes and cosmic so as you
heard kevin feige say right there
they've got ghostwriter they've got
blade and they have a supernatural side
of the mcu that is coming it sounds like
they have plans for ghostwriter which
has been reported several times as well
and he was actually cut from doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness he
was supposed to be a part of the
illuminati and for whatever reason
marvel decided he was not put in it in
the final cut but if they are actually
planning on giving ghostwriter his own
movie he could also fall into this 2024
slot as well falling into phase 5. so
although i don't think there are going
to be many more slots for phase 5 i do
think we're going to have one or maybe
two other announcements for phase 5
coming at disney's d23 event and also
keep in mind if they announce a couple
more projects for phase 5 spider-man
could also still be in there because
that is a sony announcement but let me
know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below do you think we are
going to get more projects in phase 5 or
do you think phase 6 is where all the
big reveals are going to be at disney's
d23 event let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof